the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
Studios I am Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com and Ryan sickler on all your
social media I want to say thank you
like I do every week for real for all
your support on this show it grows every
week it has since day one so
I can't thank you guys enough for that
all right subscribe to that YouTube
channel that's what really helps the
show it's a free way to help too all
right and if you gotta have more if
you're one of those people it's like man
one isn't enough then you gotta check
out that patreon you hear me say it
every week and every week some new [__]
comes up with your stories it's the
Honeydew with y'all and I highlight the
low lights with y'all and like I said
recently we just talked to a guy who was
dead for three and a half minutes
because a pickup truck fell on them
pushed them down in the water and he
drowned in the water he was dead for
three and a half [__] minutes okay
that's the kind of [__] I get weekly all
right it's five bucks if you sign up for
a year you get a month free you're also
getting this very show the Honeydew
you're getting it ad free and you're
getting it a day early for no additional
cost there's no levels and tears and
[__] it's five bucks all right now you
know what we're doing over here we're
highlighting these low lights and these
are the stories behind the story tellers
ladies and gentlemen very excited to
have this guest here first time on the
do please welcome Cipher
thank you thank you for having me you
can do the show multiple times what do
you mean because you said it's my first
time here yeah so I might have a second
or third let's see what happens okay
okay but people have done one before two
or three yeah I've already already
playing in the trilogy
yes people have definitely done it for
sure okay good because I got a lot of
stories
um well before we get into any of them
please plug and promote everything at
the top okay I'm gonna plug some stuff
you're not gonna care yet but hopefully
as the episode progresses you'll be like
let me rewind see how to follow this guy
first of all at cyphosound
c-i-p-h-a it's gonna be written
somewhere right yeah thank you uh that's
Instagram and Tick Tock all that stuff
uh I have a podcast called Juan app is
life it's the first hip-hop podcast ever
we've relaunched it during covid me and
my partner Peter Rosenberg so one up his
life is my hip-hop podcast and then I
have a comedy podcast called talk
clearlier with me and will Sylvan and if
you listen to me and will sylvan's try
to speak it's horrendous we butcher the
English language it's so good it's
really fun
so yeah so check those out
all right
um okay oh oh sorry all shows on my
Instagram and stuff so you'll see all
that stuff so Dan Van Kirk introduced us
yeah and I have definitely heard about
you I don't know you you're a New York
guy and I don't really you know do much
but stay in LA and do the road but um
I was interested because I know you have
an interesting background and you've
we're music first and you shifted into
comedy 100 so let's talk about you first
where are you from tell me about how you
came up so I'm from the Bronx New York
um
a Puerto Rican but here's the thing I'm
Puerto Rican ethnically but not
culturally so like I'm not one of these
proud Puerto Ricans I'm like my family's
from Bayamon like I'm from the Bronx
um and I grew up in the Bronx until I
was about 15 and my mom got a promotion
and we moved to Long Island so I went
from the hood to then a very white high
school all right so let's stop there for
a second are your mom and dad together
no my dad died when I was like three wow
how were they together at the time yeah
yeah yeah yeah what happened you know
you know what I don't really know he
drowned
apparently he drowned said this [__] the
guy didn't fall too drowned he drowned
but the re apparently he went fishing
with some friends something happened
with the boat
the thing that [__] him up is he lost
his glasses he was like almost legally
blind like horrible so they say he was
just swimming aimlessly because he lost
his classes and eventually he drowned
which is really sad so then
somehow my little cousin who's like my
father's sister's son got mad at me one
day calls me it leaves me some voice
messages your father was in the streets
nobody told you he got killed so I I was
like whoa what I asked my mom I'm like
what is you know is Matthew lying or
were you lying to me was he like a she's
like no he [__] drowned and like
showed me the newspaper article she's
like the [__] is he talking about so but
yeah apparently he drowned when I was
when I was just turned three so I don't
I have like literally three memories of
him man what are they he drove an ice
cream truck what kind Mr Softee classic
New York I remember being in the ice
cream truck I remember
sitting at a table and he was drinking a
Heineken
and I remember one time I was in bed and
he like leaned over and gave me a kiss
on my forehead I remember my
it was my grandmother's house in the
Bronx base um apartment and I remember
like these hooks above and that's really
it everything else I know is like
pictures
and uh yeah there's nothing I know
you're his only son yeah yeah it was
super young my mom had me when she was
16. oh wow he was 19. okay so it's like
a teenagers having a baby yeah yeah yeah
and then your mom is doing what when she
gets this promotion what was she doing
oh my mom worked for FedEx at that time
okay yeah all right she worked for she
drove the big trucks for FedEx really
they called me through the Bronx
no Westchester okay like above the Bronx
but she knew all is f like there's some
rappers from there like Heavy D Brand
Nubian she would get that autographs
with me Junkyard Dog yeah
and my mom was gangster though my mom
was in a gang when she was young really
yeah so when she delivered FedEx in the
projects the this is really cool I want
I want to write a joke about this
all the gangsters all the hood guys in
the project loved her she was like one
of them they'd be like oh they used to
think you know FedEx used to be Federal
Express yeah so they used to think it
was like cops
so so they were like nah we we know
y'all uh 5-0 but we like you
so then she's like I'm not a [__] cop
up a delivery well what are you talking
about
so what they would do to drug dealers
they would put baking grease on the
steps
but they would they would have a code of
which steps didn't have banquet Greece
so if they were being chased by the cops
they would go three five seven oh hell
yeah I love it right like this so they
would go three five eight so like when
you're running from the cause of the
ones you jump in jump on yeah
it's like a great right so they would
give her the code they're like yeah we
like you three five seven or whatever
and she was like climb up with boxes and
know come on that's their [__] too but
that's why I love Hood stuff it's like
these people are smart but they just
this condition that they're living is
[__] up but like that's genius it is
that's something that's some uh uh
guerrilla warfare [__] right
so um but yeah so then she got then she
became a dispatcher and uh the uh
whatever you call the dispatcher room
was in Long Island so she got you out of
the projects up to well we didn't live
in the projects okay but she just worked
in the project but um we lived in the
Bronx but it was like you don't know
it's bad
and see when you get older you'd be like
oh that was some
it was bad but it was no
you know I mean yeah and people always
talk about the bad stuff in the hood but
it was super fun too like people outside
hanging out music food like you know yes
bad things happen but like when you
watch gangster movies it's always like
focusing on the bad stuff it was a lot
of fun it's like families
yeah and you think about a movie it's 90
minutes two hours so even if that bad
[__] does go down they're still 24 hours
enough exactly yeah it's like
concentrated yeah and you're telling the
story but like I loved it man I loved it
so did you like your new place when you
moved to the you said you were the only
you said you were an all-white school
mostly yeah how old one year so I was in
10th Grade so I was like 15. okay so
you're starting a new high school yeah
so I went one year High School in the
city and then moved in 10th Grade so
like now I'm new you know I mean I'm the
new kid and what's that transition like
for you it was like rough like I had so
I get really dark
when I tan and like right before we
moved I went on vacation when my mom so
I was dark and I like literally first
date gym class I take all my [__] in
this guys you put it Inward and I was
like what just punched right away
and like first day I'm in the vice
principal's office and he's like oh Luis
Diaz from the Bronx like we don't want
that kind of trouble here I'm like me
what right yeah this guy just saws I had
to like readjust
and then um
and then so there was I was the only
Puerto Rican but again I don't even
speak Spanish like I'm not culturally
Puerto Rican I'm just a New Yorker so it
was me who has like a Latin name then
there was like three kids from like
South America
and it was five black kids but they all
lived in a in a group home that was in
that neighborhood and it wasn't even
together there wasn't even a black
family wow they lived in the group home
wow you know it was like a you know one
of those charity type things so it was
like no
um what's the word people use now with
lots of different people gentrification
no uh with a d like diversity diversity
why am I blinking up there's no
diversity
but this is night 90s early 90s so like
all these white kids love hip-hop
but then they were racists some not all
not not all but some I watch guys at
Ravens tailgates where like a Ray Lewis
jersey and drop the m-bomb yeah how are
you doing it no because the the stars
get a pass right yeah well he's not he's
not yeah
like what how's that working over there
but yeah that was a it was a so did you
play sports or anything like what did
you do to like ingratiate or did you
never like really blend in 201 school
music okay music
so they there's it was like
like some people were racist but they
weren't like hateful racist they just I
guess they weren't more than ignorable
and they hear their dad use the n-word
and like
if they get into a fight with a black
kid they throw the n-word out but
they're also not really racist they just
know it's gonna hurt that person in that
moment right so whatever I had a lot of
friends and then um they thought I was
cool because I was from the Bronx and
like I would like
get the new cool music for my friend and
his older brother
and then um so I started watching a lot
of yo MTV Raps video music box that was
a local video show in New York and
listening to the radio and I was like oh
I miss because hip-hop was just around
me everywhere like it was just playing
in the street and then now it wasn't so
I was like oh I missed that so then I
went looking for it and I got into like
my stepfather or my wife my mom got
married that didn't last long and uh he
had uh he had like a turntable and an
old mixer he lent me and that was it I
was in like I was I used to record on
videotape all the rap shows and then I
would try to buy records as much as I
could I got a job oh no I didn't get a
job yet I would try to buy records my
mom bought me some for Christmas and I
was just be in my room for like hours
hours hours hours just practicing isn't
it crazy though this person in and out
of your life but left you something that
stop oh they took it away
and I'm saying not the moment oh yeah
yeah not the thing you had to get into
it yeah and um they say what do they say
people are here for a season a reason or
a moment or some [__] like that like you
know what I've never even
put that together like he definitely
wasn't around long but he couldn't
turntable impact created my whole life
that's a great Point man great Point
um so
I didn't do anything else like I just
wanted to be a marine that's it I did so
you just liked music you weren't
thinking about DJing right or being
working in it you just like this
everything I did in life was a Pastime
until I turned 18 like my birthday's
April I would have graduated in June
and June 28th I was gonna enlist
so everything in life was just
I loved like Vietnam like platoon
Vietnam movies platoon and Hamburger
Hill and I just wanted to be a marine
and my mom was like why do you want to
be around I might go to uniforms and fly
baby I mean they always like so on point
and I liked order
so I was like and I didn't have no other
like goals really I didn't know anything
and I was just wait until I turned 18 so
like I was very smart but I never did my
homework
so whatever
I'm just everything is just like waiting
time to 18 wait so I'm 18. I'm gonna go
join the Marines and then I get into
music
and I go well I can't rap I don't know
how to rap I don't know how to play
instruments but if I practice DJing
for hours I'll get it it's something you
can learn and not be like so interesting
you say that because here at the school
Lana has a non-profit where I've taught
podcasting like a 101 class yeah
um but it started with her doing DJ
classes
and she teaches these kids like look you
can go out and you don't have to work at
Starbucks or Little Caesars or some [__]
like that you go out just on a weekend
do a bar mitzvah make bank and boom
you're good to go so it's a skill that
you could take out with the end of the
world and not have to hit that minimum
wage not 100 [__] yeah 100 and like now
it's so much easier now you can download
songs for free right get a laptop and a
controller and you're gone as you have
we had to spend money on records every
week
so I you know I get into that and I
start liking it more action are you
scratching like record records like I
remember seeing DJ hurricane like do it
behind his back yeah I'd run from one
turntable to the other one and [__] yeah
yeah and I wanted to be a producer
so a lot of my favorite producers were
DJs like DJ Premiere I'm like oh you I'm
young I'm like oh you have to be a DJ to
be a producer so I had to like learn it
and uh it just turned into an obsession
and I never had an obsession before so
my mom was like almost kind of worried
because I was in my room for hours she's
like what is this I was a good kid I
didn't get in trouble whatever so she's
like what's this guy doing in there
so one day I come home and the
turntables are gone
and she's like I don't want you're in
your room too much you need to go out
and I got so pissed I walked out of the
house walked down the block and got a
job at this place called chicken choice
is that right chicken Choice man pissed
off walk right into a job first place it
was literally like two blocks away it
was like a little
four-stall strip four store strip mall
you know one of them little ones donut
shop whatever I go into chicken choice I
need a job the guy goes put on apron I
mean like it's just frying chicken
making fries and zucchini strips you
know what I mean and just and then clean
the grill they had like flame grilled
chicken I would just clean the grill and
and I remember I was making money like
doing getting some tips of
and I saved up bought a brand new
turntable what's your first one Tommy
that you bought technique 1200 that's
that's the tank that's the one to this
day now they cost a lot now they cost
like a thousand dollars what was it back
then like four so back then that's a lot
of money too it's probably what it
equals today yeah 400 bucks and I saved
up and that's just two of them so you
got I had to buy one
for one
and then I bought like some somebody
gave me like a shitty mixer and I had a
shitty turntable so you would play
one record on the shitty turntable but
you would scratch on the good one okay
and then I would switch you're listening
to the the shitty one and scratching the
good one okay yeah so that the beat is
playing and then you're scratching and
then I would take it and switch it put
on this side practice on this side you
know you make way but that's what
hip-hop is hip-hop is taking
nothing and make it something you know
what I mean and um
and then I
I do that for a while then I'm I meet
some kid
and I moved out at 17.
my stepdad didn't get along I don't even
say stepdad my mom's husband we can get
along so I move out I move into my
friend's house for like two months and
then his older brother had like a
a shitty basement apartment and like the
hood in Long Island and I got down there
I had to go through their home to get
downstairs it wasn't like a separate
entrance but I was like close with his
family so it was cool so I'd be in this
shitty basement apartment I had a
girlfriend that had all this equipment
uh and I bought a car from him a Datsun
what Datsun 200 SX okay you know what
that is yeah I do remember like they
were popular maroon one were all popular
maybe sporty car yeah yeah a little
two-door yeah little speakers in the
back I was living working and then uh
and then I just yeah then I waited till
I was 18. I went to the Marines
the guy
if I was DJing I was still like learning
how to DJ that God the guy makes me take
the test apparently I got a really high
score he's like oh you he's like you can
do anything in the Marines you know you
got your choice
he's like we're coming to get you uh you
know Tuesday Morning 5 A.M
and I haven't spoken to my mom in years
not yet maybe a year
why the reason why I left you know I
feel like she picked my stepdad over me
tell me like you were leaving you left
because you felt like you or or when you
left you felt like she picked your
stepdad or your her husband over you it
was he it was just like uh
he was just a jerk and to you as well
yeah and her yeah it's her but I didn't
know as much as he was that later I
found I was really a jerk to her I see
but you know
I yeah I guess looking she was like
picking him over me with certain things
and then she took my turntables away and
then you know she was like
you know you gotta like get a real job
you know I mean what do you what are you
doing like you got to go to school for
this and I'm like I kind of like that
when I try doing this it's like no you
got to do something real my mom was a
truck driver you know I mean like she's
she's to the core like yeah she's like
get a get it like I think I went to I
took airplane mechanics no interest
but it was like learning a skill you
know I mean
and um finally I was just like I don't
know I always been like independent like
I couldn't I can't take people like
bossing me around
so I just left
and then I called her I said you know
I'm I said listed in the Marines like
I've always told you I was gonna do and
I'm leaving you know tomorrow she's like
I want to come talk to you she comes
talked to me that night and she goes
is it sure you something you want to do
because it seems now you're into this
music thing
and I go this is always what I wanted to
do and she goes yeah but are you stuck
in this mind frame of it's what you
always wanted to do but now you're kind
of doing something else
she's like the Marines are never not
going to be there so why don't you try
this for a year
and then go and I was all night up all
night and I called the guy at 4am I go
hey man
I think I'm not gonna go tomorrow or
today
I think I'm gonna take a year and think
about it and he's went off on me he
started screaming you you're soft I
thought you had heart you we had the
same experience with them same thing
right I've never told this story but you
did it it was in person like luckily I
was on the phone no no I I'll tell you
good and he's screaming I thought you
had a heart you said you wanted to be a
marine and that it literally clicked I
was like wait a minute I left home
because somebody was yelling at me now
I'm voluntarily going to a place where
they're gonna yell all day and I was
like oh I made a terrible decision I'm
not coming and that's how they let you
go yeah he never me dude no I had gone
in I was living with my grandmother at
the time my dad had died and um
in this process like she remembers my
dad going into the Navy during Vietnam
and she's telling me the whole time
don't go don't go and there was a
recession at that point I had applied
for 21 jobs I'll never forget record and
Tape Traders all these places I couldn't
get a [__] job I I became a Manny I
went and [__] helped a kid a young
boy with baseball I taught his sister to
drive all this [__] yeah I took anything
I could get yeah yeah yeah I was gonna
donate sperm and my grandmother was
going off about that but then I did
research and I learned because you think
you're gonna jerk and make all this
money but you can only do two samples
per a square radius of an area all right
because even though it's not
probable it's possible those two
siblings get together and they're
related hilarious so you can't just be
dropping loads all over the Box you know
you get one in the Bronx you get one
over here and that's it right so I was
like well there goes that [__] my
grandmother's Catholic and yelling it's
still your child you know that [__] I'm
like God
[Music]
so I go in I go in for my first uh I go
to MEPS I go in for my first training
thing and they I test really well also
they tell me I could do whatever I want
I'll go in higher as a c whatever
especially because I had some community
college credits all this stuff
and uh my grandmother dies during that
process and I'm just devastated because
I've always I just lost my father I just
lost my grandmother the way it happened
was brutal I [__] I don't have it in
me and
I call the number and it was a lady
first and she goes you know what I don't
blame you one [__] because they're
gonna fight you it's like you'd call the
number to say you're I called a number
to say I was out it was just ended up
being this Angel today yeah yeah yeah
and she's like they're gonna fight you
right but you stay strong it's not what
you want you stay strong that's crazy
okay
and I call my friend's father
um and he was a lifelong Marine he's you
know I'm out of I'm in college and this
is his dad who's still in the Marines
you know he was yeah that's right yeah
job yeah and he told me get the [__] out
he goes you're not actually sworn in he
goes what happened I go man they told me
I could do this all of a sudden now
they're telling me I got to be a jet
mechanic and the computers froze and
they're just gonna sign me in this
position and then don't worry we'll
figure it all out
I already know what this [__] is
because it is [__] so he said you're
not officially in until you swear in
that second time I go when do I do that
because you swore him once I go I did he
goes all right you won't swear in again
until the day you're going to get on
that bus and go to boot camp that's when
you swear in again that's the official
one because so many people change their
mind of course and he's like when you
get on there if you do that and he goes
get the [__] out now so I call and the
guy's doing that to me I thought you had
heart I thought you and they're just
going on on you gotta go you so you
gotta go I know I go and I'm just
staying calm I'm like yeah I know I
don't have to but you're a kid yeah I
don't know 19. I was 20. 20. like they
know you're not there yet and I'm like
my grandmother just died I need to be
around my family right now they need me
I'm not going they're like well so the
guy comes and gets me at my house really
oh yeah they went all out comes and gets
me at my home and he drives me back to
the map Center
where I sit and talk to somebody else
who's in person is doing the same thing
trying to intimidate me and scare me and
I'm just smiling yeah I'm smiling
because I know I don't have to go and
I'm not gonna [__] go and now that I
see the way you guys are I'm so glad I'm
not [__] going this is [__] and
um
yeah they [__] told me you had
somebody that could tell you didn't have
to go right because how many kids think
they already did the swore swearing I
thought that yeah I'm like no I already
swore into the thing and I remember
being I also remember testing and I was
making the guys laugh during the testing
I'm like this is some weird [__] we're
doing I was like Hey guys did anybody
stick did they stick a pencil up your
ass and these dudes would start dying
laughing I'm like I should be doing
something else here I know I should be
doing this love that and uh I [__]
the guy goes he he goes in it like he
does with you and at the end he goes so
what's your decision I go here's what's
funny to me you're screaming at me for
five minutes telling me I have to do
this and then when you wrap it all up
you ask me what my decision is and I
told three of you three hours ago I'm
not going yeah and then they let me walk
out right because you're not really in
right yeah yeah because if I was
obligated to go legally you drag me in
or throw me in cups whatever be arrested
when I left here right so yeah but it's
I I get it it's the same thing so when
you said jet mechanic I was like oh it
sent me into it I was like no [__]
that's the same [__] they did to me yeah
that's crazy yeah yep listen I have all
the respect me too I love our military I
support it but my experience and what I
was going through at the time personally
and then the experience I had with you
trying to recruit me in nah yeah it
wasn't a good experience yeah I love
that I love love those guys man so then
yes so then I just
all right so now here's your music yeah
and you dive into music I go
I go some kid I met at Community College
I'm taking a program in college studio
recording learning how to be an engineer
I'm like oh this this I can explain this
to my mom
when people record stuff there's a guy
pressing all the buttons this is what I
want to go to school for I'm killing it
it's a special program the guy it was a
national Community College he was an
engineer he created this program killing
it so he learned like music theory music
business studio recording learned
everything about working in a studio
Machinery gadgets equipment loved it
and then um I met some kid he had a rap
group he goes hey we're gonna bring the
rap group to this College radio station
this other college in Long Island
Adelphi
can I go
I've never been to a hip-hop College
radio show he's like yeah come with us
we go in shitty Studio this guy named
Wild Man Steve he would do an hour of
playing like unsigned artists and that
was at 10 to 11 and then 11 to 1. it was
a DJ named DJ Riz and he would play all
the underground hip-hop stuff but the
first hour was unsigned artists so go
there this guy brings his wrappers they
rap they gotta they're about to leave
and I go I asked the guy wow Missy can I
hang out for the show he goes yeah you
know just stay out of the way but you
can hang out so everybody leaves I stay
by myself within that those three hours
I figured out everything I go every time
someone rings the doorbell he has to go
downstairs and open the door okay
there's phone Line's ringing he has to
answer it in three hours I go hey man
um can I help you like answer your
phones and maybe open the door and get
you like food or whatever and he was
like I don't got no money for that I go
I'll do it for free it's you know Monday
nights he goes all right we'll try it
come in next week coming next week box
of donuts
early before him I'm sitting there
waiting for him
letting people in going sounds bro I was
in I was in and I every week I met like
Q-tip from A Tribe Called Quest mob deep
because they were it was like this is
like the 90s so big artists who became
big Superstars were underground hip-hop
artists is this the place you want to
get your [__] played if you want to hit
wonderful level one of them in New York
there was like five College radio
station but like they were like to us
where we listened to all the new music
this is before internet
CDs like this is where you listen to it
so this one is on Long Island a lot of
them are in the city so I am I'm up
there every week every week every week
helping out meeting all my favorite
underground rappers the alcoholics Big
Daddy Kane I got pictures from all those
days
that DJ rizz is white kid but he's
incredible
he goes oh I'm DJing a party on Friday
at this club I go hey can I
oh I know he doesn't have a car
so I go hey can I drive you to that gig
and he goes yeah I guess
bro take my [__] car go to Brooklyn
pick him up drive to the city watch him
DJ go oh this is uh this is it this is
what I do
and just worked with him
for years everyone what bro
so back then we had to go pick up Vine
if you were a notable DJ you would get
free vinyl from the record companies but
you sometimes you have to go pick it up
I'd go drive them there sit in the car
they don't just go up pick up the
records come down they're up there
bullshitting I'm sitting in the car two
hours this is no phone no iPhones I'm
not just listening to the radio and then
driving to another place driving to
another place and he'd be like yo you
you sure you wanna yep no problem no
problem he didn't have a car drove him
we go to record shops then we go to
other College radio stations just to
hang out I mean all my favorite rappers
and I'm in heaven and I've I've found my
calling this is what I want to do
then he worked at a club on Sundays
called the tunnel
he was the opener so he was there from
like nine o'clock this party was 2500
people every Sunday
he plays before the middle DJ and then
the main DJ Funkmaster Flex
I go with him carrying his crates
getting to meet everybody eventually my
friend DJ Riz kind of blows up and wants
to just go off on his own he doesn't
want to be an opener anymore
so they're like well who are you gonna
put in
safe I've been with him for so long he
trained me
I can handle it
I get in there I'm DJing from
it's supposed to be 8 30 to 9 30. Okay
the reason why they needed a DJ so early
is because first 500 girls free this was
the ghettoist club it was like jail I
was DJing in jail yeah listen
90s that's hilarious
this is like you don't have to dress
like there's a lot of clubs in the city
but they were like r b clubs and you had
to like dress up and they were on
Saturday night this is the crack dealers
drug dealers but it was the hottest
hip-hop party
so the other guy big cab he died rest in
peace he's supposed to play from 9 30 to
11 30. and then the main guy gets up so
he comes in 9 30. he sees that I'm there
next week comes in 10.
next week comes in 10 30. so I'm just
playing Killing it then he gets off at
11 30 and then I get back on and play a
half hour of Reggae before the main DJ
so I'm running around trying to learn
how to play reggae music grabbing all
over because that's a big thing in New
York like a lot of Caribbeans play half
hour reggae and it also like resets the
room then the main DJ gets on 12 o'clock
all the hottest [__] people going crazy
and like so then that guy Funk Master
Flex I'm in there for like a year or so
and he goes he's on the radio as a DJ
but now they want him to be an air
personality at seven o'clock he goes hey
you want to work with me at the radio
station I need uh I need you to same
thing I did
get the people in set up my records
bring food all that [__] he goes I'm not
gonna pay you
but I'll teach you how to get paid best
lesson in my life I'll teach you how to
get paid
take the job within weeks like I would
um any gig he got he'll be like yo I
need sites to open up so if he's getting
a thousand or two thousand I'm getting
200.
and it's just
starts the whole DJ life
and what's your first Big Gig
like on my own yeah
oh my first big gig is uh DJing for
little Kim how'd that come about so [__]
Master Flex manager her name was Jessica
Rosenbloom
she had all the hot DJs so if anyone
needed a DJ for anything in hip-hop they
called her
so little Kim
was in a you know in a group called
Junior Mafia with Biggie and then she's
gonna go solo like they're all still a
group but she's gonna do a solo album
so they need a DJ for the for the promo
run which is like all she had out was
two Junior Mafia records an r b remix
and one single
and then she's gonna go on promo no pay
so they give me three not right no pay
she did it yeah when you go on a promo
run yeah you go to like you'll go to a
bunch of radio stations around the
country and they'll have like you know
Hot 97 night you know Saturdays live
broadcast and you go perform two songs
three songs there's no money you're just
getting per diem
or maybe like a thousand bucks
whatever
and uh she gave me 300
a week
but see the thing with her that she was
hot like she was on fire so people were
booking her everywhere right everywhere
we were out Wednesday Thursday Friday
Saturday sometimes Sundays
and um so I did that for a while you
were her DJ heard you exclusively yeah
so like I go on stage I play the music
they perform
foreign
300 a week and then she uh I was like
now she's getting now her album comes
out
the album's selling like hotcakes now
she has more songs to perform now she's
getting like I watched her get 20 30 G's
you know I watched the road manager pick
up the second half 15 G's I'm still
getting 300 a week a week
so I go
hey uh this is you know it's not working
out like I I need a little more and
they're like that's all we got sorry so
I quit
they hired some other kid within like
two months like Scythe you gotta come
back
this guy this guy is [__] girls and
they're acting up messing up the shows
his records are always skipping so I
come back for 300 a show
bro I thought I was rich I have a 700
apartment like with a roommate 700 rent
I'm coming home 1500 a week bro I was
rich I bought a chain man I was out of
here oh and then all that just started
accumulating like DJ with flex DJing
with Kim getting other little gigs
sometimes Kim would do two shows a night
so that's 600 bucks instead of 300 bucks
and we just just raw and she was going
everywhere
everywhere anywhere like even rappers
weren't going because she was like
this girl talking about all this sex
[__] you know like so they wanted to see
it so we were going everywhere down
south west coast London it was great
London huh
so then what next would I have to wait
let me ask you this question all over
the place no you're not you're in comedy
enough now to know
um what bombing and comedy is like
what's bombing for a DJ have you ever
bombed have you ever [__] up played
okay anything like what what is a bomb
for a DJ though so you get booed at the
club yeah yeah oh yeah so I was I was at
um I explained to people there's a lot
of people think I made this jump from
Comedy to DJ in this crazy jump I go
it's a lot of similarities you gotta
read the room you gotta like is this a
clean show is it yeah I mean is this is
this a a more of like a a woke crowd is
this like a conservative crowd or wild
Trump be crap you know how to like still
the same jokes but you kind of like it's
an urban room this is a white room so
you got to read the room
bombing is not as bad in DJing because
you're playing hit music other people's
music so I talk a lot when I DJ I have
like a personality so I'm talking yo
we're gonna get this party right
everybody
sometimes this is not working but see in
the DJ booth you could turn down the
lights so they don't see
and just play hits hide and play hits
bro if you play the hits like if you're
bombing you can't all of a sudden start
doing this right crazy yeah
and like I'm just up there eating it
well you just it's by yourself it's all
you which I love Yeah and yeah what's
the scary part bro you could hide you
know what I'm just gonna play Biggie
Jay-Z Fuji's hits and then eventually
and then eventually like it's also I'm
DJing three hours
so you might bomb the first 30 minutes
get them back yeah and then turn the mic
back on turn the lights back on here we
go new people walked in yeah people
walking in walking out
so that's the bombs aren't as bad as DJ
the gigs might be [__] like yeah let's
give me some bad gig you know what I
don't know anything about sports
obviously you do there's a big picture
of you playing football behind
I know nothing about sports Okay so
I sometimes I didn't realize I'd be
DJing
the night of the of game seven
or
the The Fight Night of the fight bro you
go in there like those fights sometimes
go to like two in the morning you know
depending where they're at so you go in
the club and nobody's there bro there's
like 10 10 girls who are not interested
in baseball and you're like
it's one o'clock this is when I would
play all the hot [__]
but I gotta save it for when the people
come and there's a moment when you go
oh they ain't coming
they're not coming at all huh there's
like like it it starts over here when
does it hit you today it's always this
case my case
it's Case by case but like I wouldn't
expect you to say it and then the
promoter's like ah it's a little slow
right now you're like oh it's cool right
no they they coming though now guess
this is crazy they coming so it's a
little slow so you might not start right
away eventually the promoter's looking
at you like you're gonna get on and I'm
like I guess we get honest 20 people you
start playing and then like five more
come in six more come in and you're like
but what are you expecting
what are you hoping for to not packed
house is how many I know it's Case by
case but we talking about let's say all
right though I used to DJ this club
speed every week that was like
at that club was probably like 400
people okay maybe five basement crowded
fun dancing
and there's like 90 people in there and
you're like oh it's starting off slow
and then like also like
if like
Thanksgiving Eve is a big party night
that's a Wednesday but if you DJ every
Saturday sometimes that Saturday after
that Wednesday yeah not popping because
the Wednesday was popping right so you
walk in normal Saturday vibes
why was parking so easy tonight
that's a good indicator
anytime I get a good spot yeah
and it's light and they're like no no
they coming they're coming cool the
guest list is crazy something that's
making me laugh because I've heard that
[__] so many times yeah you know what it
was cool now yeah everybody's back from
college tonight there's always some
[__] there's a there's uh there's
back to college there's
um the weekend so depending on when New
Year's or holidays New Year's Eve like
if it falls on a Tuesday
Saturday's dead Saturday's dead I used
to say to these [__] every time
I get a promoter and there would be
nobody there and he's like man you
should have seen it last week I'm like
you should have booked me last week I
would I would have if you booked me but
I got I got to a point where I was
pretty popular where like we get our
money up front like we get our money
before we even go in
and um and they start oh I gotta let me
uh
I gotta run to the ATM or whatever like
I'll be over here sitting on my crates
and me and my boys would just be sitting
there waiting if if I knew them it might
be different but if it's the first time
I'm working with you no dough No show I
like that I like that I learned that
from biggie I like that is that right oh
yeah oh Junior Mafia Little Kim because
I was so excited I was like I want to
perform something yeah when you work
with Big E Jay-Z I want to hear stuff
about that for sure but that's what you
learned that no donut so if you don't
pay fully up front we're not performing
do half up front Okay half a Cent and a
lot oh and then you get the other half
when you get there you still haven't
performed with a okay got it no but bro
what used to be with little Kim she
wouldn't get out of the limo sometimes
she wouldn't leave the hotel until they
like if depending how grimy it was she
would send the road manager and then I
would go with them just to check out the
stage is the DJ booth on stage or is it
across the room
and they'll be like yo yeah I'm with kid
we're here to pick up the the posit the
the the second half
oh we you know we waited for a couple
more people I'm like oh are they getting
the money from the door like they didn't
have it already
and be like hi yo bro no don't no show
and they would call they call back the
hotel we almost we got we almost got it
if y'all want to come now nah and then
uh uh sometimes and then like a lot of
these shows were like in this day there
was a lot of drug dealers doing shows to
laundry money launder money I see okay
it was this this is the hood days yeah
right some shows were like big tours and
stadiums Arenas some were like just drug
dealer shows and they'd be like bro they
pick us up from the airport
and it was just it's just a fleet of
benzes BMWs Acuras actors so there's
like eight of us yeah and they're like
yo two per car so like what so we get in
and all these they got jewelry and they
flying in these Acuras we go to do the
show they sometimes they had all the
money for sometimes they give us the
money at the airport because they like
we don't give a [__] about this we just
cleaning up yeah there's half a million
please take this yeah yeah yeah but they
also were like you know flossing they
wanted girls at the club whatever so it
was always different but then um
so I'm with little Kim I mean
I met Eric I met Jay-Z
uh
uh in London
his DJ he only had two songs out
he had a single
we're in London and uh his DJ couldn't
get through customs for some reason
maybe passport issues so yo Kim can we
borrow your DJ so
um that's how you came to work with
Jay-Z yeah that's how I met him yeah
that's how I met him and they're like yo
can we borrow your DJ because we're only
doing two songs and then you're going up
after it so he'll just be ready to go
so I go up there
so you know turntables have the speed 33
and 45. so 45 is like faster so it was
set on 45 for some reason but they're
like yo we got to go now we got to go
now hurry hurry so I grab his record we
run on stage I put it on they're like
give it up for Jay-Z and I play it and
it's fast so it's like
there's a video of it he walks on stage
he's like what the [__] you doing man
I'm sorry because the song has no intro
and he's he Rhymes right away oh right
so he so as soon as you play it he would
rap as he's walking on stage and it was
a disaster so to this day
he'll we'll be arguing about something
he goes shut the [__] up you ruined my
first show to this day is that right
that was 19
19.
so he's he's still friends with him yeah
I worked for him three different times
so he didn't say [__] off after that huh
gave you another shot bro let me tell
you something about Jay-Z
um that guy is funny
like he doesn't show it a lot in public
he has a real cool persona but in
private and in his raps he's so smart he
says a lot of slick [__] but personally
super funny is he so he got it you know
he was laughing at the moment whatever
we and we talk [__] about it and and I I
and he'll [__] with me like he still but
that's the thing he still mentions it he
still brings it up I'm like shut the
[__] up I love it
um so yeah I worked with it but then I
worked with like
I didn't work with her but I met
everyone at the radio station
97 98 99
was a big turning point for hip-hop it
went from underground like biggie was
one of the first wave to make it
commercially successful
98 is DMX Jay-Z Nori Big Pun all going
Platinum which was new for us oh out of
New York too right all out of New York
the locks
High 97 was the mecca was the culture so
everyone came to the radio station so
I've just met everybody and they would
have album release parties mixtape
release parties uh birthday parties and
then they always need a DJ and the radio
guy I was shouted out on the radio so it
would guarantee be more you know crowded
everybody would make money
so yeah I met all my favorite rappers
um that I became an a r and a couple
different labels what's that mean a r
so a r is the guy at the label who he's
like a liaison no I know who he is oh
what does a-n-r oh a another actual what
is it yeah it's artist and repertoire
repertoire but that's like an old yeah
it is old I know
it's so old but I never knew what the r
yeah we've got to get our repertoire
Bugsy Malone's label
um so yeah so I'm uh I'm a hot DJ
This Record Company hires me they like
we want you to be like an a r and tell
us if our records would work in the
clubs you DJ at so I'm listening to
records that won't work that won't work
oh that'll work you know then
um
then um so now we're in the 2000s
and that's what I was trying to tell you
earlier about working for free it's like
my my
I'm like a forever intern in my mind I'm
if funkmasterflex called me today I was
like yo bring me a sandwich I'll go you
want mustard on that to this day bro
that's great yeah I wouldn't be here if
it wasn't for him yeah my list when I
finally one day get an award I already
got the list in order
Mom thank you step dad [__] you but
thanks for the turntable boom boom boom
boom everybody who gave me my shot
so now it's the 2000s you know Pharrell
like the Neptunes
they're blowing up they're the hottest
producers they want to start their own
label
so I go hey I have a r for this label i
a r for this label smaller but still had
some records I was like can I end off of
you they're like ah our budget's kind of
low I'm kind of just doing it myself
until we build it up I was like I'll do
it for free
do it for free so they're like do it for
free I might do it for free so they're
like okay so I go hang out with them at
the studio now I'm in the studio with
mega Stars
that a lot of them I already knew they
met me like I'm the cool kid from HOT97
I don't drink I don't smoke everyone
loves me
just a cool guy
but also like
if anyone's DJ was sick on the road they
would call me can you do this weekend
with us because I'm like a reliable last
minute guy drive anywhere
and so like that reputation is starting
to take hold
and I go work for the um the Neptunes
and uh
I worked there for like six months I
would just Pharrell was so talented the
Neptunes were so talented it was a very
easy a r job I would bring the records
to the record companies hey this is what
Pharrell did last night oh we love it
just easy
six months and then I go man this is
amazing I learned so much I gotta I
gotta go figure out how to make some
money though because I you know I can't
be here all the time and Pharrell goes
we don't pay you
nah they forgot
they forgot they forgot because we don't
pay you what do you mean I go bro I've
been doing this for free I just want to
do it he goes you have an office you're
on he goes aren't you on like the you
know you just threw a a record company
he's like aren't you on like the payroll
and direct record
no I just have like a guest pass every
day he goes what the [__] so he calls
people gets me in officially
and he gave me back pay for like three
months how about that all right okay so
what well the point is I I try to tell
everybody I don't have any connections
as a kid there's no famous family
members I have saying not great
education
nothing
how that's why the Marines were like the
BET like you don't need anything just go
in and you [__] become somebody
so I had to figure out a way and like I
always offer to this day I'll do it like
can I come like do you need help now
they go yeah just calm safe you don't
have to do anything but I find a way in
and working for free
is a great way to
get your foot in the door well what
you're working for is the experience you
don't get that dollar right there but
that's that's the long game right the
experience is harder to go that's right
you're not gonna get there I don't give
a [__] who it is no teacher is gonna
teach you something better than Jay-Z
yeah you know then Pharrell
Funk Master Flex yeah DJ yeah you're
seeing also what you're learning is how
each one of them handles their business
business how they maybe things you would
do differently that could work better
for you there's so much I tell Tom all
the time when we're out look if Segura
called and said I don't have any money
anymore I would still go out and [__]
work with it because I love Tom and I
love just being around them but I tell
him and his manager all the time I'm not
just happy to be here I'm paying
attention to what you guys are doing
you've built an Empire yeah what a fool
I would be to just you know not be there
like I watch how they handle thing uh
watch how they I don't take care walk
into a room I walked into your spot I
was like okay got that on the wall oh
put the logo here with the cameras like
I watch all that [__]
so that's you can't get that I agree and
I say to Young Comics asked me and if
you if you getting in this to make money
then forget it because you're gonna work
for free for a long time you gotta
[__] love it and you loved DJing
that's the other thing loved it you
didn't mind working for I'm not gonna
work for free for [__] I don't love and
I'm not gonna work for free forever like
we talked about you don't want to be get
taken advantage of but no but like a lot
of people are you know you might have to
gotta have a day job I'm lucky that my
day job was a night job right well I was
DJing at night I had no sleep but it was
I loved it so you're DJing for the
biggest hip-hop artist in the world
biggie yeah the uh did you work with
biggie you said yeah right after okay
right but Kim what makes you shift gears
and at what point do you do that into
comedy see this is not we don't have
enough time this is we need more we need
more fruit we need more fruit so
um this is all weaved together but so
okay so the reason why I was getting
into why you work for free
so I'm working for I'm friends with most
deaf and Talib kwali
at an art at their label
most deaf you go he went on a five you
know I gotta do five colleges wanna come
with me give me a thousand a show
where Little Kim was giving me 300 a
show and Little Kim's supposed to be a
hip-hop Superstar most Dev is like
underground and I go why am I making
more with him with her and he goes he
gave me the best advice he goes yo pay
your friends he goes what's the well I
don't understand people pay your friends
I was like yeah I'm gonna give this guy
more money because he's an expert right
but my friend does the same thing right
so whatever
um so I'm hanging out with most Dev
Talib kwali and they're friends with uh
Chappelle Chappelle's loves hip-hop he's
a hip-hop guy
I mean Chappelle one night with them
we're hanging out
and I meet him another night we're at
some party and he goes hey I'm gonna
walk over this the first time I ever
heard the words the comedy seller he
goes hey I'm gonna walk over to the
comedy Center to do a set you want to
come at some girl with me I'm like can I
bring the girl he goes yeah come so we
walk you know 20 blocks that's normal in
New York you walk 20 blocks
and he's like yo what how did you start
what'd you do so we're talking hip-hop
he goes into cellair walks in
does two and a half hours wow
and this the cell it was crowded but
it's not like how it is now or it's like
a [__] Megaplex of comedy and he
gotta go sit there we watch him two and
a half hours I mean I'm amazed because
the thing I loved about him is [__] we
talked about on the walk was on stage
yeah
and I was like how about we just how the
[__] did he do that so we hang out so
afterwards the girl left she's tired I
gotta go home bye I'm staying here
and so afterwards we're hanging out and
he goes I'm doing uh doing some pilot
for Comedy Central he's like could you
like DJ like like when the people are
walking in and so there's like some
energy I go yeah I guess we go we shoot
the Chappelle show pilot wow I meet Neil
Brennan
he goes uh yeah just play music while
people coming in and in between while
we're shooting you know great do that
time goes by nothing's mentioned about
it then I bump into him again and he go
I go what happened with that thing that
we did you the thing you shot he goes oh
yeah yeah they're doing it they're doing
it oh okay
you want a DJ on it I go uh do you want
me to DJ that you don't seem like you
care he goes I don't know whatever I
don't know boom it's your pal show
so he shoots the sketches and then we go
in front of a studio audience and he
show like like on the show he shows the
sketches to the audience so he wants me
to play in the room like before people
like he loves music to this day he
always has a DJ on stage he loves that
energy so I'm the DJ on the Chappelle
show when you watch Chappelle's Show the
first thing you see is my face like ha
and it goes past
but I'm
[__] around with him when he's
warming up the crowd like Donnell would
warm up and then Dave would come out and
do some time and I would like play songs
and he'd laugh and like if he mentioned
something I'll throw in a song and then
I would say something back to him and
one day he goes you're [__] funny bro
you should do comedy and I go come
why would I do combo
I'm a DJ like I'm whatever shut up and
that was like oh two and like bro like
how much further would I have been if I
listened in O2
then oh so you didn't start then no oh I
see what are you talking about yeah I
don't even know what he meant then as I
grow on the radio
people keep saying now like now my
personality on the radio not just a DJ
so people keep saying I'm doing stupid
pranks I'm calling
two Chinese restaurants on oh dude
conference yeah and they're calling each
other like you call me no you can't what
do you want yeah what do you want anyway
but I'll put it on the air yeah
yeah uh bro remember the Nextel chirp
phone yeah so I I recorded the sound and
when songs were playing on the radio
I'll just go and drop it into the song
so people would think they're phones I
don't know how many people looked at
them oh yeah constantly and people would
call up your phone's on the air I I give
I was like no I don't even have a Nextel
I hear the noise I go what are you what
are you talking about
so anyway so people would be like you're
funny on the on the radio and I just
kept hearing it
and um I was on MTV too
and uh one time I was on MTV I had this
show called direct effect which was a
hip-hop show but once in a while they
would bring me on TRL it's like if they
had like a
an urban act yeah yeah they'd bring me
in
so Will Smith
I'm [__] with Will Smith and in the
commercial break he goes you're funny
because you do comedy I go no because
you're funny and then I swear to God
Jamie Foxx said the same thing to me
and then that it just keeps twirling now
I'm in the New York hip-hop scene where
I mean listen if you've got Chappelle
and you know [__] Will Smith but if you
guys Chappelle and and I hear you [__]
uh [__] him will our uh Chappelle and
[__] Jamie Foxx telling you and Like
Rappers too like but still those are
comedians yeah who've done it who've
been there hero all the way to Mega
stardom like bro I'm a smart guy like I
know when
the universe is sending you signals
right and I um
I go and I'm I'm in the New York hip-hop
scene where every DJ is like a tough guy
and I'm corny I'm funny I say even when
I used to DJ clubs I used to I didn't
know I was doing bits I didn't know what
it was like called but I'd be like yo
there's so many Puerto Ricans here
what's up we gonna party tonight my
car's right out front nobody steal my
ring yeah in a nightclub yeah and people
would look up at the booth laughing and
then dancing
so anyway so I keep hearing funny so I
go I guess I gotta do something with
this
uh what can I how can I make money
so
they're like just just do a night at a
club
you know uh what's a guy's name old
school guy Bobby Collins you know Bobby
Collins yeah Bobby Collins comes to my
radio show to promote his weekend at uh
whatever at Comics that it was a club
called comics
the booker was there with him and I go
I'm always I want to try doing like a
comedy night what should I do and I see
her light up like the guy from Hot 97
wants to do a comedy night she goes to
one of our nights she's like do like off
night so I'm like all right what's your
worst night she goes Tuesdays boom
Tuesday
I started a show called don't get gas I
was like my little slogan
first night
rappers ball players no [__] packed all
black and Spanish kids like my fans the
club had people trying to buy bottles
the club is like what the [__] just
happened they didn't think it was going
to be anything
so I do that for like five years that's
oh seven
so I go on stage I had a host I just
when I said thank y'all for coming we're
gonna have a great night sit back relax
we're gonna have some fun that's all I
did
the host takes over
and I go up in the middle I say one
thing get like a tiny laugh
okay right and then every month a
monthly show every month I go a little
more a little more then like by the
fifth month no hosts I do it right and I
get a little laugh then I find myself
like oh that worked trying to like but
like I never had to go through like the
open mic scene because I had a I built
your own I had a crown it was packed
every Rick Ross Little Wayne Drake
everybody in there I don't know Sports
again I would say but like John Stockton
was in there and my boy goes that's big
my boy goes He dunked on Jordan say he
dunked
okay
my boy John Stockton's here like Matt
remember when you dunked on Jordan Crowd
Goes Crazy I go I don't know
all right Crowd Goes Nuts ah New York
all right
so then like a like a year year and a
couple months in
like Talent Capone it was like more of
an urban show but I always put I never
liked it to be all black I always mixed
the audience the the comedians
because I love I love comedy I just
didn't think I wanted to do it I used to
watch you know the the Caroline's hour
and um live at The Improv all those
shows Johnny Carson everything with a
comedian but I never thought I wanted to
do it so I always make sure it was mixed
Comics white guys book I'll book three
black guys you book two white guys Mike
vecchione Dan naderman they're all in
there and um about a year and a half in
Talent Capone uh uh uh a couple other
guys who else uh who's a mark Vieira
they go okay they sit me down they go
okay
looks like you like doing this
you want to actually try doing stand up
I go yeah I'm doing it this is not
you're [__] around
they go this doesn't count these are all
your fans they're gonna laugh at
whatever you say
if you really want to try it you got to
come with us I was like whatever I'll go
anywhere and then this is where the the
two years of bombing
I don't get why I'm cocky I don't give a
[__] I'm funny okay
Hood rooms in Queens ghetto Jamaican
spots to the
bombing I get the little Fame off my
name oh [__] Cipher sounds oh [__]
myself
my favorite one is I'm at a uh this
Puerto Rican bar in Brooklyn
I don't speak Spanish
uh but Puerto Ricans love me I had a I
had a show on the radio by now I'm doing
the morning show so like I'm on fire so
the morning show was a black a Puerto
Rican and a Jew walking to the station
okay that was the show it was all about
different viewpoints of New York City so
it was me Puerto Rican my friend
Rosenberg the Jewish guy and this girl K
Fox and like whatever news subject would
be like how do black people feel how do
Latinos feel about whatever
so the Latinos are loving me now because
I'm like representing so I go into this
club
I didn't know about going last
headlining none of that [__] so the guy
puts me last so I'm like whatever man
I'm sorry for sound I'll kill it so
three guys go up and the guy before me
uh Edgar Rivera does his whole set in
Spanish
crushing bro so the stage was
uh behind me is like the window to the
street you can see the sidewalk and but
they had like a black curtain and then
there was like an emergency exit right
there bro I go up they bring me up the
Crowd Goes Nuts and within a minute it
was like Cricket that's fast I can't
even tag
the last guy you know what you're going
to know what the [__] he's saying you
know what he said about Coca-Cola yeah
it was so bad
I literally just walked out there did
you really and how long it
couple minutes six seven
he just knocked out of the emergency I
walked out the emergency exit I think
somebody said something like somebody's
like yo you corny you corny
I walked out my boys are with me they
have to like run out the front
the owner comes out yo what the [__] yo
I'm not paying you I got I don't want to
be paid I want to get out of here so
that was my worst bomb
not my worst bomb ever but the one where
I didn't go back up for like three
months okay right so I have a monthly
show I would just hire a host no stop
doing that one
you were killing me bro I couldn't shook
you I couldn't and I go I don't and then
my my guy Talent
oh God so it's like you know talent I
know who he is okay no I'm personally
but I know great guys so I was on Hot 97
he used to do he was the comedian on
KISS FM which is across the hall every
morning like you get up last night
what'd you do how'd it go you know he
would give me like so for like three
months I wouldn't even go in there he
goes yo what the [__] going on bro he
goes why are you not telling me but I I
can't I can't he's like well you have to
he's like the only way go back
so finally I did it and then then I
learned how to take bombs you know I
mean but that was in that interesting
like not only do you have to learn how
to write jokes and then your own voice
like how do I put this art form into my
body and process it out this way you
also have to learn how to [__] eat
[__] yeah you gotta learn how because
the Nugget the the gold is found in that
[__] it's like okay 20 minutes a bomb
for 15 but there's five minutes of
something in this yeah yeah and then you
gotta dig it out and figure out how to
use it I actually like that now because
you um what's a truer gauge to what is
really actually fun right and they get
that you got that treatment I've seen
some celebrities get who've done stand
up and they they get a first maybe five
minutes because of who they are yeah but
if they're not bringing it the Crowds
Are they don't give a [__] like okay
great you had a TV show or you had some
movies man but you're sucking ass right
now right yeah and even after you bomb
there will still be fans that come up to
you that want to picture but you know in
that moment it was not going well
um but I like now I finally when I bomb
now I literally go I'm bombing I mean
and just be honest
yeah and then that Sparks if you have
funny if you're just a joke writer maybe
you know there's funny people there's
pristine joke writers there's guys who
are hybrid you know I mean there's like
all these different uh architects of of
a comedian
so like
if it's not working I just talk to the
people and start finding stuff and those
turn out to be the funnest shows now you
know but the [__] is when you're with
other comics and you're bombing and then
you hear them laughing oh it's our
favorite
the true Joy it's our favorite I did a
show watching this [__] die up
here because especially if you're done
or if you know you're next or like God
damn it but people turn around look at
you like you think that's funny you're
like nah that's not why I'm laughing bro
I didn't I didn't even do a show I used
to open for Michael Che a lot
and um like Michael Che when I met him
he was a fan of me and he was nobody and
I used to do my show and they're like
can you put this guy Michael Che on oh
yeah and he met me he was excited to
meet me so we were like like this and
then
he's [__] out of here but we went I
went hung out with him for the okay I
don't know Sports what's the Super Bowl
of colleges the uh well the national
champion yeah that's just so one year he
got booked to do that to do stand up for
the teams okay I think it was in Atlanta
so is Michael Che JB Smoove Roy Wood Jr
three
[__] killers
so we go
it's a hotel
one of them hotel conference rooms they
got some food for the kids there's a
college kid so they're not really
supposed to be going out so they provide
entertainment before the big game
so we go in there
each one of them ate all the [__] they
did all of them really so there I mean
we're there's four people left three
people laughing me
falling over on the floor these players
are looking back at us like what the
[__] are they laughing at so the first
one goes horribly then we go walk
through this tunnel to the hotel across
the street to do the same show for the
other team
and now they're like you think it's
gonna be better you think it's gonna be
written I'm like yeah it's gonna just
and then worse
worse because I think the only
difference that I could think of is that
one team was from Georgia so they were
home
and the other team maybe it was Alabama
or something so they're out of town so
they were more uncomfortable and it was
the funniest [__] ever
the best but the second one they all
expected the bomb so they were just
ready for it yeah it was like that's
right they were making jokes for us
exactly right and then there was some
[__] in there and um sometimes I would
be like yo Chade I was funny you should
you should use that you should make that
into something so you find the good [__]
in there
but yeah so
it's fun man and now here you are do you
still DJ not much really you don't it's
all comedy now all comedy and like I
left the radio to do comedy full-time
right like it was at a point I left
so I was at high 97 for 17 years oh wow
[__] that's a long time especially in
radio I never thought I would leave
I thought I'd be there my whole life
15 years great the last two horrible
management okay
my biggest problem right is um
I don't
I don't promote myself enough I've been
part of so many different
great things happening but I don't get
my credit I'm like this like I always
say when I die it's going to come out of
the woodwork and like oh my God this guy
was he did so much he connected this
person with this person this person yeah
but I don't say it and sometimes I don't
care but then I think I'd be further
along if I did you know I get all mixed
up
so last two years were horrible
management [__] me they didn't the new
guys didn't really know that Blood Sweat
and Tears I put into the last 15 but I
was doing stand up a little too
I asked Chris Rock on the air hey how do
you get into the comedy seller I always
hear about the comedy seller he goes oh
you got to be recommended oh can you
recommend me but I'm joking around on
air
but then off there he goes you really
want a recommendation he goes I'll wreck
you wow I go oh my God I would love it
how do you do it because you get an
audition you gotta you know do another
so he so that was December
he gives me his assistance number never
hear from him Christmas New Year oh he's
a [__] [__] he's lying whatever
I quit my job
um February
2015.
I had all this drama
Monday I go [__] it I'm quitting Tuesday
we do like the paperwork the severance
Wednesday is the worst day of my life is
a place that I went to for
six days a week for 15 17 years I'm
sitting at home like what the f my wife
goes to work I'm like what the [__] do I
do
I do I'm like all right baby I gotta go
DJ for pitbull or somebody like
Pitbull's a friend of mine maybe he'll
let me DJ for oh my wife's like seven
months pregnant
uh maybe ask say Jay-Z if I can work
back when it's something
I'm like [__] it just Wednesday I just
sit and watch Abbott and Costello movies
eat pizza just [__] it I'll do I'll deal
with it tomorrow
Thursday I get the call from Chris
Rock's assistant oh my God sorry forgot
to tell you rock got you an audition
when
tomorrow oh [__] all right so I'm like
oh [__] I go to audition
comedy seller crush it
get past it the seller literally I go oh
I made the right choice this was life
telling me boom now the next four times
at The Cellar bombed the river yeah yeah
bro they put me on a 1 30 after David
tell just
I go oh maybe I didn't make the right
decision bombing bombing but then the
fifth one I caught one and I go okay got
it you know what I mean but the first
four bookings
if she was there the lady who works at
SD I'm I'm sure she would have got rid
of me
dude that's great I mean so it's
interesting to me to go from
such a high level where you were as a DJ
but to follow a passion and start over
completely again from zero zero from
zero it's really impressive dude good
for you you should be proud of yourself
I always don't say zero because I did
have a following to get my room back you
did and you had Connection in the music
slash comedy world but brought it
together zero I mean from as far as
stand up you had no family in this [__]
you didn't come up in that world as far
as proper stand up you used your music
and and
um radio connections to to
um yeah [__] to transfer I mean you
really shut it I'm surprised that you
don't DJ anymore do you ever do like a
once in a while or anything if it shows
or [__] like that yeah but you're not
out there doing like obviously you can't
the problem is
how much time you need to put into stand
up and I don't want to jip myself also I
don't love the new music like I loved
music from the 90s to the 2000s 90s
hip-hop was still my favorite [__] it
just holds bro at any moment if Jay-Z's
like can you DJ a 90s party bro am I I
have it ready right now I can do it
right now yeah I have my laptop like but
the new stuff I still keep up with it I
still like some of it but I don't love
it so let me ask you this question then
what do you love more comedy or DJing
now comedy
comedy is that this comedy supersede
music just music in general are you
still more loving I don't just because
you don't perform or play yeah what do
you like more
it's not even it's hard to compare
comedy like I'll go
I see comedy almost every night even if
I'm not on the show man bro I I music is
my life is my life blood it's always
there
but like I even did improv at UCB I had
a hip-hop improv show where I would
bring my famous rapper friends to tell a
story and we would do improv off of it
okay I had a TV show with that that I
almost sold I did sell it
um I saw what was that guy's name
Harvey Weinstein
yeah I sold it to Harvey wise David why
is he called me and I didn't that didn't
work out but um but yeah I love [__]
it's almost here's the thing it's almost
the same thing to me I listen to music
in my car but I also listen to
uh you know all the comedy channels on
Sirius satellite radio and podcasts
so it's like has this it's like a rhythm
it's like a a rhythm
a way to get your mind off the stress
and all this [__] [__] scoville's one
of my favorites that's how I met uh Dan
Van Kirk
and I was here a couple weeks ago I did
their podcast and I was supposed to go
home that night and skull was like I'm
doing this show at uh what's that show
he was doing
some little theater in frog town is that
a thing
he was doing some little show I changed
my flight
because I never saw him live yeah he did
he did he did maybe 20 minutes because
he was like kind of bringing other
people up I'll I'll change I lost money
on that yeah on that deal but I love it
man that's it I love it
well first of all this has been a great
episode I hope so it has it feels like I
was all over the place no you weren't it
was well that was your life by the way
you just talked about you've been all
over the place because that's how you
lived life yeah
um advice you'd give to your 16 year old
self now uh it's so funny you ass I
literally just said it
get your credit
right
um
I get I get all weirded out about
talking about yourself I don't want to
look narcissistic I don't want to look
like I'm me too
um feeling myself too much but then I
know guys you know DJ Khaled mm-hmm I
know yeah how do you know who he is
because he says it in every
[__] song
in every commercial every interview
every calendar was literally under me I
got him his first shot on Hot 97 like a
guest DJ
cow's my boy and he just oh see he's a
superstar now
and he just promotes himself like crazy
now I don't know if I want to be that
but I don't do it enough I'm like oh the
work I'm gonna head down in the work get
the work done be funny
no offense there's a lot of kids on Tick
Tock that are not funny there's a lot of
people on stage that aren't funny
and they and
their
doing something to get them way more
shows than I got but I look at them I go
but it's not that funny it's also not
sustainable you're gonna get one
audience they're not coming back to grow
with you as you become a a comedian and
a different person you know what I mean
because economy is going to change yeah
and they're not coming back after that
yeah there's a lot of guys that'll sell
one [__] ticket and that's it
so don't even worry about that yeah
don't worry about it but like there's a
there is a middle ground there where I
do have to
say the stuff I've done and and oh for
sure yeah like I just did a TV show with
LL Cool J
where we search for hip-hop artifacts
it's coming out on a e in the next year
and I'm like I'm like I told myself I'm
like
make sure you focus on promoting that
you're part of this thing yeah because
you'll just keep doing your spots keep
doing stand up and like there's a thing
out there that could help but you gotta
tell the people also there's so much
good [__] out there today yeah that if
you don't tell these people it's out
there they don't [__] know it's out
there because they're living on Netflix
or Hulu or Amazon they're not jumping
over to a e they might not have you know
what I mean so yeah you gotta tell
people yeah I'm interested it surprised
me because I thought you might say
um start comedy in 2002.
oh
yeah but that's but no it goes the way
it's supposed to go yeah I was just
curious if you felt like you really
missed an opportunity but it doesn't
feel like you have
no I knowing how long it takes to get
good at stand up I did wish I started
when Chappelle gave me that little piece
of little nugget because I could have
still did everything here's the beauty I
was on the radio in the daytime comedy
prime time is seven to midnight and
still could have DJ'd midnight to four
or in those time frames
so that's the only thing I regret but
but it's not that because
like like Paul Mooney like all the
comedians used to come to the radio
station and promote their weekends or
whatever and I asked Paul Mooney pulling
oh you're a legend you know I just
literally a little advice this is why I
don't ask comedians advice anymore I
need a little advice how do I you know
do comedy
get on [__] stage okay that it's I
was gonna say it earlier because the
young comedians asked me they ask all of
us yeah and you do sound like you're
pushing them away and shoving them off
when they ask you but it's it that's it
there's no program that says get in this
and after six months you'll do this and
you'll be paid this and you'll get a
title and ain't none of that [__] it is
figure it the [__] out and there's only
one [__] way to do and that is to get
on stage again and not just once again
and eat [__] over and over over and over
keep going back yeah yeah so 16 year old
Scythe I would because
interesting 16 year old Scythe yesterday
it's been my name since 16. I love it
but I I uh always no matter what I did I
would have always went for it so I don't
have to give myself that advice because
I always was doing that like you find
something you like
like the Marines DJ like just go in but
also promote it you know what I'm saying
big it up and and and don't be afraid to
work for free I don't know if I would
have told myself that but I'm telling
you that
is the camera on me Christian um
um just to get in Che Michael Che hey
can I go on the road with you I don't
really like bringing people on the road
I'll go for free flew myself out
got there no intentions of getting on he
goes you want to do five yep
five because you're on the road now this
is just us five turns into ten turns
into every week I mean Chappelle hey man
Chappelle brings me to DJ his shows and
I go
can I after I DJ can I do five
you want to do five yeah two five all
the other Comics that usually go first
love it because no one wants to go first
5 10 20. now Chappelle brings me to
Denver just me and him I'm DJing 20
doing stand-up 25 bring him up but all
that comes from just going hey can I do
this can I do that right that's all it
is this is great dude thank you again
for thanks for sharing the story uh so
you don't give out honeydew I'll give
you that mug bro
no we don't eat because I thought it was
gonna be a you'll throw it away you'll
just throw it away
um plug and promote everything again
please
at Cyber sounds that's all my Instagrams
um c i c i p h a and then sounds will
come up
um the show coming out hip-hop Treasures
top of the year uh podcast talk
clearlier with Will Sylvan and the Juan
app is live with Peter Rosenberg
thank you again man and uh thank you all
as always uh Ryan sickler.com Ryan
sickler on all your social media we'll
talk to you all next week
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]